la différence avec tap le premier
confinement c'est con avec st et on sait
également comment d'abord un on a un
vaccin et deux fautes eurent raté quand
même on traite on peut pas parler de
tout aujourd'hui mais il faut voir des
progrès thérapeutiques et il ya une au
mieux le traitement soignants etats unis
sont en train d'arriver et on traite
déjà mieux et stéphane caillet connais
ça très bien mais on a également par
exemple au global voice network et des
traitements qui sont en train d'arriver
pour les formes graves qui peuvent
également changer mais ceci dit par
rapport à votre poids moi je pense que
personnellement je ne donne pas la vie
de ne par confiner complètement en me
disant tant pis pour les morts qui aura
j'ai l'impression peut-être à tort mais
j'ai l'impression que si on avait une
politique vraiment combinant bien sûr
quand même à des mesures de restriction
donc on parle pas du tout de liberté
ahmed de mesures de restriction forte
mais pas un confinement total avec
vraiment les mesures de précaution et
une vaccination de masse
moi je pense personnellement peut-être à
tort et je pense que les cours qu a
rappelé stéphane caillet vont dans ce
sens je pense personnellement qu'on peut
éviter encore une une vague massive y
compris dans les hôpitaux
[Musique]